euh avant de de d'accueillir et de
donner la parole à Madame la Ministre
euh comme c'est notre dernière audition
je souhaitais saluer et remercier les
membres de cette commission qui ont
participé aux travaux certains avec
énormément d'assiduité je voudrais citer
Anel babo andreé chassigne monsieur
président présent aujourd'hui Grégoire
de fournass Jean-Luc fugit Laurent cdel
mathil digier Nicole LEP Éric martinau
Marie pochon loï prudom mie Nicolas
turquois je je remercie ses collègues
pour les intérêts et leur contribution à
la réflexion de cette
commission euh qui a travaillé de
manière très très dense particulièrement
depuis le mois de septembre et je je
voudrais aussi remercier les
administratrices de l'assemblée qui nous
ont accompagné
euh je dis accompagné en fait don le
travail est absolument indispensable
pour que nous puissions conduire ce type
de travaux alors je suis heureux
d'accueillir madame Sylvie rotaillot
vous êtes ministre de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur merci d'être
parmi nous madame la ministre
euh donc là dans la dernière ligne
droite des travaux de cette commission
nous avons
auditionné beaucoup de ministres en
exercice et anciens ministres s'agissant
d'une politique publique qui repose sur
plusieurs administrations centrales
quatre principalement dont la dont la
vôtre agriculture santé environnement et
puis recherche
euh votre votre administration vos
services vous-même vous êtes pas euh en
pilotage de cette politique publique euh
l'agriculture euh est évidemment plus
sur le devant la question de la santé
complètement centrale naturellement la
transition écologique mais euh la
recherche est absolument déterminante
euh elle est même elle a été évoqué euh
pratiquement à toutes les occasions et
euh pardonnez-moi de le dire comme ça
mais l'échec de cette politique publique
puce qu'il y en a un puisque les
objectifs que la nation se fixeelle ne
les atteint pas
euh c'est pour parti les l'échec de la
recherche dans la mesure où on peut se
dire est-ce que la recherche a démarré
assez tôt est-ce qu'elle avait assez de
moyens est-ce qu'elle est suffisamment
coordonné est-ce que elle elle est bien
orientée sachant que ce que le
rapporteur appelle les technosolutions
n'en sont pas puisque nous savons tous
que il ne s'agit pas de remplacer une
molécule qui devient interdite par une
autre puisqu'il y a une une recherche
plus multifactorielle à conduire sur une
transformation des exploitations et donc
en fait une recherche agronomique donc
la question du transfert et de
l'articulation entre la recherche sur
plus long terme et son déploiement est
aussi une question qui se pose donc euh
voilà je pense que vous allez pouvoir
nous éclairer sur la façon dont
vous-même vous appréhendez la
contribution de la recherche à la
conduite de cette politique publique et
surtout à l'atteindre des objectifs la
façon dont vous concevez la partie
gouvernance entre les différents
organismes de recherches qui sont
concerné il y en a il y en a beaucoup
euh le jugement critique que vous pouvez
avoir là-dessus de cette dimension
interministérielle nous interpelle
énormément nous sommes là au cœur d'une
politique publique
[Musique]
de beaucoup de points de vue dans le
fléchage financier et dans la
gouvernance il y a un grippage et un
manque de lisibilité sur la poursuite
des objectifs sachant que ils peuvent
être partiellement contradictoire je
pense à la biodiversité contre la
question du carbone bref je suis un peu
long dans mon introduction je vais
m'arrêter je vais donc vous laisser la
parole pour des propos liminires d'une
dizaine de minutes après quoi je
rapporteur va réagir il y aura un
échange de questionsréponse avec vous et
puis on ouvrira les échanges au m de la
commission présent avant de vous céder
la parole je vous rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse qu'elle
estansmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'en vertu de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relatif au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires vous êtes
tenu de prêter C de dire la vérité toute
la vérité r que la vérité et je vais
donc vous demander de lever la main
droite et de dire je le
jure merci madame la ministre je vous
cède la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés alors tout d'abord vous dire que
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête sur effectivement les
objectifs de la maîtrise des impacts des
produits phytosanitaires sur la santé
environnementale et humaine vous avez
effectivement choisi de consacrer une
partie de vos travaux aux enjeux qui
sont liés à la recherche et je voudrais
d'abord vous en remercier et ce n'est
pas moi qui vais vous dire vous
rejoindre comme quoi c'est effectivement
un point essentiel est important
l'approche de la France est en effet une
approche basée sur la science et la
recherche est une composante essentielle
de cette stratégie
écophyto réduire l'utilisation de ces
produits
phytopharmaceutiques nécessite la
production de connaissance scientifique
pour identifier comme vous l'avez dit
les innovations de rupture ainsi ensuite
que la massification des outils et de
ses solutions toutes fondées sur la
science cette la mobilisation de mon
ministère pour que la France atteigne
ses objectifs et fortes conséquences je
vais vous le montrer tant en terme
d'implication dans le pilotage vous
l'avez dit que dans le financement et
que ce soit dans le cadre du plan
écofito mais aussi des appels à projet
de l'Agence nationale de la recherche la
NR aussi de France 2030 qu'au niveau
européen et c'est ces différents points
que je vais aborder le premier je vous
propose de revenir très brièvement sur
la contribution de mon ministère à cette
STR stratégie écofito 2030 et à sa place
dans la gouvernance vous le savez le
pilotage de la stratégie écofito
s'appuie sur les quatre ministères vous
l'avez dit en charge de l'agriculture la
santé l'écologie et la recherche mon
ministère collabore donc étroitement
avec le ministère de l'agriculture sur
les aspects recherche mais aussi
formation de la stratégie écofito 2030
nous avons contribué à la rédaction de
l'axe recherche innovation et formation
de cette stratégie qui vise à mettre en
place des programmes de recherche mais
aussi à intégrer les sujets qui sont
liés à ecofyo dans sa dans sa partie
formation mon ministère participe
également toujours en collaboration avec
le ministère en charge de l'agriculture
à la création de l'axe dédié à la
recherche d'alternatives chimiques et
non chimique aux produits
phytopharmaceutiques qui est une
composante majeure tant en terme d'
objectif qu'en terme de
financement France 2030 en permettant
une augmenta ah pardon je j'ai collé une
feuille excusez-moi donc le deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais venir
concerne le financement de la recherche
sur ces produits
phytanitaires tout d'abord un axe du
plan écopyo 2 plus qui est consacré à la
recherche et à l'innovation il est
dirigé par le comité scientifique
d'orientation recherche et innovation ce
comité étant composé de 40 experts guide
les actions de la recherche supervise
des projet cohérents et favorise la
valorisation des résultats c'est un
budget annuel de 7 millions d'euros qui
est alloué à cet axe provenons des fonds
écofyo gérés par l'Office français de la
biodiversité pendant de l' écofyo de
plus 10 appels à projet ont financé 41
projets de recherche soulignant a le
dynamisme de la recherche dans ce
domaine il est à noter que sur la même
période
l'inserme a également réalisé une
expertise collective sur le thème des
pesticides et de la
santé la recherche dans ce domaine ne se
limite pas à l'initiative écofyo puisque
l'ANR est un financeur aussi important
de la recherche sur les pesticides en
effet l'ANR a financé de 2008 à 2022 251
projets de recherche sur les pesticides
pour un total de
108,6 million d'euros soit une moyenne
d'environ 17 projets par an avec un
budget annuel d'environ
7,2 million d'euros donc par an en 2022
une hausse significative est observée en
raison de l'appel à projet spécifique
sur le chore d'con France 2030 en
permettant une augmentation
significative des financements de la
recherche dans ce domaine est également
levier important pour atteindre les
objectifs fixés par ce plan
écofyo l'objectif de France 2030 qui est
objectif dont le nom est investir dans
une alimentation saine durable et
traçable inclut ainsi diverses
initiatives visant à réduire cette
utilisation des pesticides ces
initiatives comprennent le grand défi
biocrôle et biostimulant le grand défi
robotique agricole le programme des
équipement prioritaire de recherche du
PEPR agroécologie et numérique le PEPR
sélection végétale avancée et le projet
prioritaire de recherche le PPR cultivé
et protégé uniquement autrement pardon
ainsi que le PPR
outreem ces programmes sont tous pilotés
par l'inrae mais avec aussi d'autres
partenaires et il couvre des domaines
tels que le biocontrôle la robotique
agricole la transition agroécologique la
sélection végétale mais aussi bien sûr
l'agriculture sans
pesticides le financement total s'élève
à 204 millions d'euros sur 7 8 ans et
des dispositifs tel castragal financé
dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
maturation prématuration de France 2030
favorise également la partie maturation
des résultats issus de la recherche
en parallèle d'autres programmes de
France 2030 comme le programme
équipement prioritaire de recherche
Onew ou encore le PPR océan et climat ou
bien encore le futur PEPR santé des
femmes santé des couples finance des
recherches sur les effets des produits
phytopharmaceutiques sur la santé
humaine et l'environnement même s'il
n'en constitue pas l'axe principal pour
ces projets pour résumer le fin
total des actions de recherche qui est
lié à cette stratégie
écofito s'élève à environ 45 million
d'euros par an englobant l'axe recherche
des cofito les appels à projets de l'ANR
et ceux de France
2030 toutefois ce montant ne prend pas
en compte le coût complet qui est estimé
à environ 135 millions d'euros par an si
on inclut les salaires des chercheurs
enfin au regard de la diversité des
actions de recherche et des résultats
qui en découlent ce que l'on appelle les
expertises scientifiques collective ou
Esco sont aussi un outil précieux
commandité par nos quatre ministères
mené par l'in sererme l'in Rae et
l'Ifremer elles permettent de dresser un
état des lieux des connaissances
scientifiques disponibles sur un sujet
mais aussi d'identifier de potentielles
lacunes de connaissance sur lequel
appuyer
la programmation de la recherche pour
produire de nouvelles solutions mais
aussi éclairer les décisions
publiques les programmes européens enfin
financent aussi des recherches sur les
objectifs écofyau l'intégration du sujet
de la protection des cultures comme une
priorité de recherche au niveau européen
était monsieur le rapporteur l'une des
recommandations relative à la recherche
dans votre rapport de 2014 au niveau
européen donc les ambitions en matière
de protection de la santé et de la
biodiversité se matérialise par exemple
par la stratégie
biodiversité l'axe zéro pollution du
Green Deal ou bien encore la stratégie
farm to fork de la ferme à la fourchette
qui existe au niveau européen le
programme Horizon Europe intègre les
préoccupations lié à l'agroécologie et
au produits phytosanitaires avec
2431 pro financé depuis son lancement la
France joue un rôle clé en coordonnant
des projets majeurs visant à promouvoir
des pratiques agroécologiques à
l'échelle européenne plusieurs
partenariats dans le cadre d'horizon
Europe tels que le partenariat
agroécologie ou bien encore le
partenariat pour l'évaluation des
risques liés aux substances chimiques
dit le parc sont alignés sur les
objectifs
écofyo le par partenariat agroécologie
prévu pour 2024 contribuera donc à la
nouvelle politique agricole commune mais
aussi à la stratégie farm to fork de
l'Union européenne mon ministère y
contribuera à hauteur de 14 millions
d'euros sur 7 ans le parc donc mobilise
200 partenaires de 28 pays et vise à
évaluer les risques des substances
chimiques de nouvell génération alignant
ainsi ses objectifs sur la stratégie
ecofito 2030 il est soutenu par la
France avec un financement estimé entre
3 et 4 millions d'euros ce partenariat
s'inscrit dans une approche onealse une
seule santé pour mieux comprendre et
protéger la santé humaine mais aussi
l'environnement de l'exposition aux
substances
chimiques mon 3è point avant de finir
mon propos concerne les outils au
service de la recherche à grande échelle
et sa
massification atteindre nos objectifs
nécessite la production de connaissances
scientifiques mais qui permettent aussi
d'identifier ces innovations de rupture
ainsi que la massification des solutions
basées sur la science par le biais
d'outils tels que les infrastructures de
recherche mais aussi le réseau
défi alors pour les infrastructure de
recherche deux infrastructures de
recherche contribuent fortement aux
objectifs des cophyo la première phénome
est dédiée à la phénomique végétale et
caractérise des génotypes sous divers
scénarios environnementaux soutenant des
progrès en imagerie pour la détection
d'espèces ou bien aussi de symptômes de
maladie accessible aux acteurs publics
et privés Phenom a été financé à hauteur
de 29 millions d'euros par le programme
d'investissement d'avenir les PA entre
2012 et 2024 pour cette plateforme le
deuxème plateforme lter za
infrastructure dédiée à l'étude des
écosystèmes regroupe elle des sites
instrumentés pour des observations à
long terme sur ces
écosystèmes certaines zones ateli
portent sur les impacts des produits
phytopharmace pharmaceutiques comme la
zone atelier saine ou bien la zone
atelier environnement ruraux qui
regroupe en fait plusieurs
acteurs pour les pour les
l'Observatoire Opal surveille la
pollution pollution agricole aux
Antilles et il est prévu qu'il reçoive
un financement complémentaire de 2
millions d'euros dans le cadre du
programme prioritaire de recherche dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure outrem
piloté par l'IRD l'Institut de recherche
pour le développement afin d'explorer
plus largement les questions de
transfert des polluants ou bien encore
l'impact sur la
biodiversité le réseau maintenant
démonstration expérimentation et
production de références sur les
systèmes économes en
phytosanitaires défi pour la
massification des solutions ce réseau
est essentiel au plan écofyo il vise à
tester à promouvoir mais aussi à
déployer ces techniques agricoles
réduisant l'usage des pesticides tout en
favorisant des pratiques économique
environnementale et sociale performante
il repose sur deux réseaux le réseau dit
des fermes de défi qui comprend 3000
exploitations engagées volontairement
dans la réduction des pesticides mais
aussi le réseau défi exp qui est une
expérimentation de 41 projets sur
environ 200 sites
sélectionnés le réseau des 3000 fermes
défi a démontré une réduction de 26 % de
la pression pesticide sans impact sur le
rendement et constituant l'un des succès
des cofito le dispositif sera pérénisé
avec un budget annuel d'environ 10
millions d'euros et la qualité de de la
diffusion des résultats ce qui est un
point important sera prise en compte
dans la sélection des
projets je voudrais terminer mon propos
sur les perspectives à venir avec les
travaux d'élaboration de la nouvelle
stratégie ecofito 2030 qui poursuit qui
poursuivent un double objectif le
premier la réduction des usages des
produits phytopharmaceutiques et des
risques pour la santé humaine et
l'environnement et le second
l'adaptation des techniqu de protection
des cultures pour ne pas laisser les
agriculteurs sans solution les
principaux axes de la nouvelle stratégie
écofyo 2030 ont été proposé lors du
dernier comité le dernier COS
scientifique qui s'est tenu le 30
octobre dernier et qui fait actuellement
l'objet d'une large consultation l'un
des cinq axes de cette stratégie porte
spécifiquement sur les enjeux de
recherche et d'innovation ainsi que de
formation et prévoit un programme de
recherche dédié dans l'objectif
d'accentuer l'effort de recherche le
volet sur la formation revit également
une importance particulière à la vaille
d'un renouvellement des générations dans
le monde agricole afin d'accompagner par
la formation à cette transition
agroécologique la stratégie détaillée
sera dévoilée début 2020 24 à l'issue de
la période de consultation en cours et
je serai vigilante à ce que les actions
de recherche soient ambitieuses mais
aussi réaliste et pleinement intégré à
cette nouvelle stratégie ceci afin que
le potentiel des travaux de recherche
qui existe depuis de nombreuses années
soit pleinement exploité pour atteindre
effectivement les objectifs de ce plan
du point vue de l'organisation de la
recherche en France nous allons
prochainement mettre en place des
agences de programme
thématique l'objectif est de mieux
coordonner dans un champ donné
l'ensemble des acteurs de la recherche
afin de définir des stratégies claires
de faciliter les réponses aux demandes
sociétales et de politique publique mais
aussi d'améliorer cette visibilité de la
recherche trois agences de programme
contribueront à définir les priorités de
recherche dans le champ des
phytosanitaires elles seront présentées
prochainement par le président de la
République l'articulation entre ces
trois agences sur un sujet comme les
produits phytosanitaires comme sur des
sujets comme oneelse devra être défini
afin qu'elle contribue effectivement
efficacement et qu'elle continue à
contribuer aux objectifs de ce plan
écofito 2030 je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre pour
ces propos liminires très dense vous
nous avez déjà donné beaucoup
d'information on vair prendre le temps
de
réagir monsieur le rapporteur je vous
laisse réagir au propos de la ministre
avec une première série de
questions oh pardon il faut il faut
laisser la parole au rapporteur merci
Madame la
Ministre merci pour votre propos
liminire qui qui est très complet
tellement complet que jeir besoin de de
de descomoser de de pour recomposer une
vision une vision éclairée nous y tenons
je crois l'un et l'autre euh je vrais
tout d'abord parce qu'il y a une grosse
actualité au Parlement européen avoir
votre réaction sur le rejet du règlement
sûr qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui même et
qui est comment l'interprétez-vous et
quelle est votre action merci alors
peut-être effectivement comme ça vient
de se passer je préfèrais pas réagir en
en direct et sans avoir effectivement
les biens puisque j'ai je suis pas j'ai
pas eu effectivement ce retour complet
donc je pourrais vous retransmettre si
vous le désirez cette réaction mais je
je je préfère pas vous donner
d'information ou erronée ou incomplète
effectivement par rapport à cette
nouvelle qui vient de tomber à l'instant
ou en tout cas il y a peu de
temps merci c'est c'est pour notre
commission un un coup de tonner terrible
puisqu'on s'apprêtait à amender un
programme gouvernemental écofuto 2030
qui lui-même était articulé fondé sur la
dynamique d' règlement c'était la grande
innovation cé un règlement plutôt qu'une
directive donc c'est c'est un fait
absolument majeur pour notre commission
d'enquête c'est un c'est un
bouleversement et personnellement je
peux vous le dire une immense tristesse
quoi donc voilà je je voulais je voulais
avoir votre réaction bon euh deuxème
élément il y a
aujourd'hui une demande française
notamment portée par des parlementaires
no collègues écologistes mais relayé par
toute sensibilité je crois que le
président de la commission du
développement durable va le relayer de
révision de la directive ou du règlement
euh rich j'ai un petit euh doute c'est
un règlement ou c'est une
directive c'est un règlement ça donc
c'est du du règlement rich euh est-ce
que vous partagez le fait que c'est
c'est c'est c'est une urgence pour la
prochaine mandature européenne parce que
il y a de nouvelles menaces sur les sur
les sur les pollutions chimiques il y a
de nouvelles connaissances il y a une
sciance qui a progressé nous avons
besoin de de réviser cette directive
est-ce que le gouvernement français la
soutiendra
merci alors c'est effectivement un point
comme la tout à l'heure vous l'avez dit
c'est effectivement des points qu'il
faut regarder et qui seront éclairés par
les différentes conclusions c'est
quelque chose qui sera attentivement
regardé pour voir comment cette
évolution peut avoir lieu et on étudiera
en interministère enfin au niveau du
gouvernement euh le portage finalement
de de d'une évolution possible ou pas
mais c'est quel quelque chose qui sera
regardé avec précision et attentivement
très
clairement merci vous avez
évoqué sous des sous des canaux divers à
la fois par les échelles géographiques
et par les par les canaux de financement
j'ai noté ANR France 2030 et et tant
d'autres des coalitions des des des
groupements et cetera bon autant de
choses qui ne me sont pas très
familières mais je bon alors dans ce
Maqui j'ai repéré une somme quand vous
faites le total vous avez fait une
recomposition un peu à la manière don
une inspection le fait elle regarde elle
recompose l'ensemble par qu'on fait trop
peu dans l'examen des des textes
budgétaires et on trouve 45 millions et
puis vous dites mais il faut le mettre
au regard de 135 millions des chercheur
alors juste une question de pédagogie il
y a pas de contradiction mais il faut
nous expliquer de quoi on parle
qu'est-ce que les 45 millions s'ils ne
sont pas de la dépense de la ressource
humaine des chercheurs c'est c'est le
matériel de labo c'est quoi c'est enfin
qui qui quoi dans quoi qu'on comprenne
tout à fait et enfin merci de cette
question parce que c'est un des points
souvent on donne les coups des projets
de recherche non coout complet
c'est-à-dire en dehors de la masse
salariale en dehors des salaires de
chercheurs et je pense que il est
important de représenter parce que sans
homme et femme il n'y a pas de recherche
effectivement le coût complet donc vous
avez raison 135 millions c'est avec les
salaires des chercheurs qui participent
au projet les 45 millions se tourent
l'argent d'équipement de fonctionnement
qui vont permettre de réaliser les
projets c'est hors salaire alors il peut
y avoir des contrats de doctorant mais
hors salaire de chercheurs permanent
donc ce sont du fonctionnement et de
l'équipement pour permettre de faire la
recherche de ces appels à projet et si
la différence entre 45 et 135 ce sont
les salaires des chercheurs
permanents donc on va bien noter 135
millions au total consacré hein c'est
pas c'est pas 45 + 135 c'est5 don voilà
ok très bien et les 2/ers en gros sont
sont c'est salaire des des chercheurs il
s'agit bien de recherche publique sans%
public puisqu'on puisqu'on fonctionne
par appel à projet est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser s'il peut s'agir par
exemple d'institut privés de de de
fondation je ne sais quoi enfin ce coût
là enfin cette dépense là de 135 comme
je l'ai dit c'est l'ANR donc c'est de
l'argent public c'est l'agence nationale
France 2030 c'est les paysa c'est de
l'argent public et c'est le plan écofito
donc donc c'est la somme des projets
financés par ces trois sources de
financement donc de l'argent
public juste pour mémire nos
administrats sont sûement noté mais la
part écofyo parce qu'on est bien dans
tous les inspections ont pointé que on
était sur un euh quelque chose de très
compliqué c'est c'est un labyrinthe hein
c'est le plan écofyo bon protéiformme
multipartenaire bon plus personne se
trouvve les inspections ont demander une
simplification nous allons relayer leur
leur plédoyer euh en l'occurrence tout
n'est pas dans le plan écopyo a le plan
stratégique national et dans la
recherche il faut rajouter mais quelle
est la part du plan écofyo qui est de
l'argent prélevé notamment sur la RPD et
qui nourrit ce qui est spécifique
àcofito et ce qui est ce que vous
rajoutez très justement dans les autres
programmes c'est juste la part descofyo
s'il vous plaît c'est 7 millions la part
écofyo c'est 7
millions voilà c'est 7
millions l'appareil cofito je pense
qu'il faut le mettre 7 sur les 45
puisque c'est uniquement une nature
financière il n'y a pas de masse
salariale de chercheurs dans ces 7
millions d'cofito donc c'est aussi dans
les 135 mais c'est 7 millions dans les
45 millions c'est-à-dire vraiment de
financement de fonctionnement ou
d'équipement de projet et c'est 7
millions
ah l'exercice on va y arriver mais on va
essayer de recomposer d'accord il faut
acheter on va vérifier que dans les
travaux d'inspection dans les
composition budgétaire on a bien intégré
les les vol de recherche parce que le
travail que vous avez glissé cette
question en amont le travail que vous
avez fait est précieux parce qu'on va le
livrer comme tel voilà il est et merci
vous avez un document qui qui qui le
décrit et qui l'explique on on le
joindra bien sûr à notre commission
d'enquête merci c'est des sommes
conséquentes tu ve les avez-vous mis en
regard en regard du montant des
recherches privées mené par notamment
les
firmes phytopharmaceutiques voire des
distributeurs et d'autres opérateurs
concernés dans cette filière et quels
sont les moyens pour recomposer ces
sommes alors non on n pas la partie
privée c'est toujours compliqué nous à
la ministère de la recherche sur la
partie alors sauf quand c'est une partie
privée qui en complément d'un appel à
projet public c'est pas le cas là mais
la recherche vraiment au niveau privé
nous n'avons pas reconstitué ici donc je
peux pas vous le donner et je pense que
c'est vraiment de façon globale je vais
vous répondre au niveau de la re cherche
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui en France la
part de financement privé mais
globalement sur la recherche comparé à
des financements si on regarde au niveau
européen reste faible donc il faudrait
la regarder dans ce domainelà mais au
global sur le domaine de la recherche
nous avons la la France a une part
faible de de financement par le privé de
la recherche ou de la Red si l'on
compare parce que petit ou grand ne veut
rien dire si je compare je dirais à des
pays européens équivalents on est
effectivement la part de dépenses et la
part de recherche privée reste faible
mais je n'ai pas l'information sur ce
domaine là en
particulier je je quitte à poser une
question idiote quand vous
composez encore une fois je c'est pas un
domaine d'expertise pour moi donc je
cherche à comprendre c'est on est là
pour ça d'ailleurs euh quand vous
comptabilisez la recherche privée vous
comptabilisez la recherche que consacre
une firme quelle qu'elle soit et sa
taille hein çaut une start-up une
multinationale une ETI euh à au progrès
au sein de son entreprise ou sa
contribution à un programme de recherche
nationale c'est oui en fait ça dépend on
on fait les deux c'estàdire qu'on a les
deux volets parce qu'on regarde pas la
même chose suivant ce qu'on regarde l'un
ou l'autre et on demande les deux mais
en déclaratif c'est du déclaratif la
plupart du temps pour avoir le résultat
et il est intéressant d'avoir et en
particulier pour les projets européens
et les typologies de projet européens la
part du privé qui va correspondre je
vais vous prendre un exemple après
ensuite avec une part publique et une
part privée dans un projet dans lequel
vous avez de l'Académie publique jusqu'à
de la RD privé et puis ensuite il y a
effectivement la part red purement
privée et on regarde les deux je
voudrais prendre même si c'est pas
directement relié dans le France 2030
nous avons les projets des bioclusters
en santé et vous voyez un peu le lien
quand même et dans ces bioclusters en
santé euh souvent il y a c'est des
partenariats public privés avec à la
fois de la recherche publique fait par
des académiques donc des institutions
publiques et des entreprises privées
France 2030 apport une part de
financement au biocluster et les
entreprises privé doivent apporter une
part complémentaire à peu près du même
poids donc ça c'est des choses qu'on
regarde parce que je dirais qu'on on le
fait avec le privé et on c'est plus que
du déclaratif puisqu'on participe au
finance et on a les budgets pour la part
purement privée c'est du déclaratif en
général que l'on a comme
somme je vous demander de de nous
communiquer les données à disposition
notamment ciblé sur les questions qui
nous intéressent donc les questions de
de recherche en en phytofarmacie
et qui nous permett de nous et les
solutions qui nous permettent de nous en
affranchir je dis ça je suis un petit
peu étonné qu'on mobilise pas un levier
de connaissance de cette recherche
privée qui est qui est fiscal c'est
c'est c'est l'avantage fiscal du
CSR est-ce que d'après vous on peut on
peut en recomposant sur les principales
firm phytopharmaceutique connaître euh
leurs efforts de recherche tels que
financés par la puissance publique
française euh est-ce que c'est un
indicateur qui nous permet de recomposer
cette
somme on on regardera le le point là du
cire nous on a effectivement la part de
cire qui participe ce point est aussi
lié à la l' agriculture donc on faut
qu'on regarde avec mais on vous fera ça
sur la part cire et la par financement
privé mais ça va dépendre aussi une part
là de recherche privée en agriculture
mais oui on on a les parts cire en
recherche donc on vous fera remonter le
au niveau du cire je pense qu'on peut je
regarde on vous on vous on essaiera
d'avoir le plus fin détail c'est jusqu'à
quel détail parce qu'encore une fois le
cire est aussi sur pas du déclaratif
mais un suivi et on vérifie sur certains
projets et donc on pourra vous faire un
bilan de ce qu'on a au niveau du
cire c'est l'information précieuse et
nous-même nous sommes curieux demain je
serai je ferai une saisie sur pièce et
sur place à ber sur ces questions et et
quelques autres concernant l'industrie
phytopharmaceutique donc on pourra
croiser nos informations mais unorté la
connaissance en la matière est assez
donc il y aura pas des fêes surprise à
ber puisque je l'annonce publiquement
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas ce qui est
recherché ce qu'on veut re chercher
c'est les pièces intéressantes pour
recomposer euh les chiffres d'affaires
les bénéfices les taxes et et les
efforts de recherche financé par la
puissance publique dans dans dans
l'industrie phytopharmaceutique voilà
voilà ce que je voulais public privé on
sait pas trop dire la proportion même si
globalement en France on a plutôt une
puissance publique investi dans la
recherche par rapport à d'autres pays
plus libéraux néanmoins on ne sait pas
dans ce domaine-là identifier pi mais on
peut croiser nos regards et peut-être
mieux y arriver en tout cas on on vous
en serait reconnaissant une des question
que nous avons abordé en amont de cette
de cette audition madame la ministre
c'est la question des programmes de
recherche européens alors c'est
compliqué au niveau français j'imagine
que ça all encore plus à l'échelle
européenne néanmoins vous n'avez pas
évoqué cette
perspective qui est horizon horizon
c'est c'est c'est alors encore une fois
pédagogie hein je je je veux qu'on
comprenne tous ceux qui nous suivent
puissent comprendre horizon c'est moi
j'ai compris que c'était euh des des
grandes des grandes des programmes
plurannuels voilà bon on est
actuellement dans une phase d'évaluation
c'est ce que j'ai compris vous me
contredirez le cas échéant et on est
dans un moment où les pays-membres les
États-membres la Commission le Parlement
j'imagine vont faire des
propositions est-ce que euh est-ce que
vous avez connaissance alors il y a des
travaux autour de oneels une seule santé
est-ce que vous avez connaissance d'un
d'un programme un petit peu majeur à
l'échelle européenne qui porterait sur
ces questions-là notre sentiment et
j'attends vraiment des éclairages de
votre part autant que possible c'est que
en France des travaux sont engagés dans
ce sens notamment par l'inrae en
partenariat avec le monde de la santé
animale de bon et ceter bon il y a des
choses qui sont faites à l'échelle
onusienne on a l'alliance entre l'oie
l'OMS et la FAO qui a aujourd'hui plus
d'une décennie he et qui commence à
produire des résultat dans une cette
logique là d'une recherche combinatoire
globale et cetera des solutions est-ce
que à l'échelle européenne nous
disposons d'un programme PHARE
structurant identifié comme tel dont
c'est la mission et qui pourrait être
utile à à notre effort de réduction de
la
phytopharmacie oui alors peut-être en
deux parties premièrement C programme
Horizon Europe effectivement monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes dans une phase
d'évaluation de l'ensemble du programme
et nous allons rentrer bientôt nous y
sommes pas encore dans la phase de
proposition au euh
2024 en 2024 milieu 2024 donc on a là
nous nous mettons aujourd'hui tous les
acteurs en tout cas côté académique et
mon ministère autour de la table pour
préparer le moment où au moment de
l'Europe nous allons je dirais porter
des propositions pour réfléchir au
prochain programme Horizon Europe donc
là au niveau de la commission Europe
c'est l'évaluation du programme Horizon
Europe nous on prépare dans les pays
dans les États mais va commencer la la
préparation du futur ou les propositions
plutôt en 2024 donc voilà pour le
calendrier des définitions finalement
des flagship ou des des des des sujets
prioritaires ou des grandes orientations
qui seront porté à l'Europe et du bilan
d'évaluation qu'on devrait aussi avoir
en 2024 je regarde au niveau horizon
Europe pour prière partie pour la
première partie évidemment puisque
horizon Europe va continuer mais pour la
partie qui est finie puisque c'est la
première étape donc voilà pour horizon
Europe de façon générale dans notre cas
à nous ce que fait la la recherche la
recherche française en Europe et comment
porte l'Europe peut-être un point c'est
le partenariat au niveau européen qui
s'appelle parc donc ce partenariat pour
l'évaluation des risques des risques qui
est lié aux substances chimiques ce
partenariat au niveau européen il
mobilise 200 partenaires dans ces 200
partenaires il y a 15 partenaires
français 15 acteurs français tous les
autres sont de différents pays européens
il y a 28 pays dans ce projet parc qui
est porté au niveau de de l'Europe donc
ce projet il a vraiment pour ambition de
concevoir une évaluation des risques des
substances chimiques comme je disais
mais des substances chimiques de nouvell
génération afin de justement dans
l'objectif de mieux protéger la la santé
et l'environnement donc
c'est pour nous dans les 15 partenaires
ils le mettent en lien il l'articule
avec le plan ecofyo clairement pour
pouvoir avoir cette articulation avec
l'Europe et ce partenariat c'est
celui-ci qui est financé par la France
la part France donc soit en ink via les
opérateurs comme l'inrae ou autres soit
aussi avec un financement qui est estimé
par la France entre 3 et 4 millions
d'euros qui participe à ce projet donc
ça c'est point et c'est un gros projet
le deuxième c'est à travers horizon
2020 donc avant l'Europe a financé une
vingtaine de projets sur les pesticides
auxquels participaient des équipes
françaises et ces projets qui sont
terminé ceux-là ont été financés à
environ une hauteur de 20 million
d'euros
et c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que sur
ces projets là sur cette vingtaine de
projets on a un recul aujourd'hui
insuffisant dis an sur horizon Europe
pour avoir des chiffres consolidés mais
c'est en cours et puis peut-être parler
d'une autre initiative qui est plus sur
du
onealth sur une vision santé mais qui
est très illustrative de la coordination
de ce qu'on est capable de faire au
niveau national européen et
international il s'agit du projet
présode ce projet présode qui est
preventing zon ce sont les
maladies tout ce qui est lié à
l'émergence des eonos euh ce projet
perzot c'est d'une part un projet PEPR
donc projet prioritaire de recherche
français avec un financement de 30
millions d'euros sur 5 ans et il est
pilodé par l'IRD le cade et lin Raay et
c'est aussi une initiative
internationale euh issue du One Planet
Summit qui a été initié par le Président
de la République hein organisé en 2021
en France et aujourd'hui en mars 2023
puisqu'il y a eu un point c'est 210
partenaires
internationaux issu de monde à la fois
scientifique mais aussi associatif
académique et les gouvernance de
gouvernement de 25 pays
qui ont signé on va dire une déclaration
d'intention présode et qui travaill sur
cette sur ce projet présode à l'échelle
internationale donc c'est un exemple sur
plutôt une Valance santé globale avec
l'émergence des
eonoses de ce qui peut être fait et de
ce qui est fait sur certains projets
comme parc au niveau européen donc cette
santé globale mais aussi avec des
impacts agriculture parce que la santé
globale c'est plus une vision globale
holistique et donc il faut la décliner
en projet c'est juste énorme les
différents projets scientifiques ou
impact qu'on peut avoir à partir de
cette vision de cette de ce concept de
santé globale et ça c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui pourrait être porté
qui serait discuter en travers nos
acteurs que mon ministère peut discuter
pour préparer aussi un projet 2020 mais
c'est dans les axes aujourd'hui qui sont
discutés comme vous le voyez il y a des
projets en cours et c'est un projet
enfin c'est une vision un concept qui
est largement
porté pour être une question de
curiosité il y il y a un grand programme
ài autour de l'eau je sais plus comment
je je me trompe sur le nom c'est ài
ou à quoi je sais plus enfin il y a il y
a voilà il y a y a un grand programme
haut qui ressemble terriblement à ce que
vous dites sur la prévention des zos ou
sur bon donc donc il y a plusieurs
projets euh qui qui qui qui font écho
aux recherchesusiennes et aux
institution onusienne et à ce que nous
faisons en France est-ce que sur le plan
européen vous pressentez que
une architecture plus claire en la
matière une
orientation une direction plus claire en
la matière serait serait serait une
proposition pertinente il y a besoin de
de structurer d'organiser tout ça ou
alors il faut de manière paragmatique
prendre les sujets les uns après les
autres c'est une des questions qu'on
pose parce que quand on arrive nous au
bout de au bout quand même de nos
auditions quand on arrive au bout de nos
auditions on découvre que obtenir 25 %
de baisse de phyo c'est de
l'optimisation de la for tion de la
performance bon voilà si il faut aller
plus loin ça suppose une reconception
des systèmes agricole et cette
reconception elle met en branle des
questions de de de de métrique
d'ensemble c'est les bilan carbone la
contribution à l'atténuation au
changement climatique ou non les
questions de souveraineté alimentaire
les questions de biomasse et de leur
arbitrage et CER bon bref et et
rapidement on voit que tout est un peu
lié c'est qu'on doit avoir une politique
pour pour pour régler les questions des
phyos il faut une politique de
production animale et choisir un système
d'élevage c'est en France pour être
pragmatique et des relations
commerciales qui les protège et non pas
qui les fragilise tout se tient quoi bon
et c'est pour ça que je vous interpelle
non seulement sur la prévention des
maladies mais sur comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait engager une transition
écologique qui soit en sécurité
sanitaire au vu des impacts multiples
des des dangers d'aujourd'hui et cetera
des dangers qu' pressend dans dans
climatique et toutes les conséquences
qu'il a et qui sont encore plus
dramatiques depuis quelques jours on a
eu des annonces qui sont qui sont qui
sont qui sont il sont terribles quoi bon
euh depuis 2 jours je crois on a appris
que que que les les processus
d'accélération qu'on avait prévu sont
sont démenti ils sont pires voilà bon
ils sont pires bon euh est-ce que on va
je je je on en avait parlé un peu avant
il y a pas de surprise hein est-ce que
vous pensez n veut pas faire du design
ou de la communication quoi mais faire
une proposition en disant l'Europe peut
renforcer un programme global autour de
une seule santé qui soit au service de
la prévention des risques et en même
temps d'une de de comment d'une d'une
cohérence avec les transitions liées au
changement climatique et cetera est-ce
que ça vous paraît pertinent estce que
c'est quelque chose qui est trop
fragmenté aujourd'hui qui m'rêit
destunifier et renforcer si c'est pas
pertinent de votre point de vue
j'hésiterai à en faire une proposition
vous avez une responsabilité importante
dans votre
réponse merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour la PR
alors je pense que c'est c'est un c'est
vraiment un point qui rejoint c'est la
même question sur le Wels pour moi que
sur les points au niveau biodiversité
climat c'est-à-dire que c'est des
visions holistiques et systémique donc
c'est pour ça que j'insistais sur le
oneels comme quand on traite climat
biodiversité sur le côté très holistique
et systémique on ne peut pas définir des
priorités de projet parce que sinon on
ne traiterait pas l'ensemble et on
oublierait les interactions donc on peut
pas aller euh quelque part au niveau
très euh comment dire directif sur un
grain trop fin mais de dire aujourd'hui
et je pense que c'est les discussions
qu'il y aura dans les prochains
européens comme euh de définir des
grandes priorités des grandes
thématiques dont oneelse avec les
risques sur effectivement la santé mais
oneelse encore une fois c'est un spectre
très très large qui va se décliner en
projet alors je peut-être un exemple
aujourd'hui à l'Europe il y a depuis
quelques temps je pense 2 ans ou quelque
chose comme ça il y a ce qu'on a appelé
la définition de mission c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose qui
justement rejoint cette vision plus
thématique plus transverse et pas de de
projet très disciplinaire ou finin je
vous en cite j'ai j'ai pas la 5e mais on
a la mission eau on a la mission climat
on a la mission cancer et on a on a la
mission ville par exemple vous voyez
c'est vraiment à la fois des priorités
actuelles mais assez transverses ou
pointu donc c'est vrai que c'est une
discussion et une étude qu'il faut qu'on
ait sur quel grain on se place est-ce
qu'on pousse une vision très large ou
anels où est-ce qu'on descend à un grain
plus faible sur effectivement des
impacts de points particuliers et je
pense que c'est vraiment le travail
qu'on doit faire avec les acteurs et
l'articulation des priorités nationales
et Inter et européenne on va parler de
l'Europe à faire je pense que l'exemple
de présode est un bon exemple de travail
d'articulation sur l'émergence des EOS
entre le National et l'Europe je pense
qu'il y a d'autres projets comme ça sur
le oneelse sur les exposom ou autres qui
sont traités et je pense que nos agences
de programme par rapport à des priorités
thématiques ben vont représenter vous
allez avoir la réponse quand on
annoncera euh c'est pas euh je je vais
Ren déflorer si je dis qu'il y a une
agence de programme en santé et c'est
vrai que dans la notion de santé même si
on l'a pas affiché comme ça la notion de
oneelse va être très présente à décliner
mais par contre la santé ne pourra pas
travailler tout seul sans avoir une
interaction à côté avec celui qui va
s'occuper du climat ou celui qui va
s'occuper de l'agriculture alimentation
donc à la fois c'est des gros blocs donc
il faut des agences de programme qui
s'occupent et qui anime les acteurs et
qui est la coordination avec l'Europe et
à la fois il faut avoir aussi le lien en
transverse et c'est tout le travail
interministériel et je pense de pilotage
de l'État et du ministère qui doit avoir
là-dessus donc c'est un peu matriciel
entre ces grandes thématiques
coordonnées état Europe et entre les
thématiques parce que c'est un concept
très large un pilotage et une
coordination un peu comme avant on
disait interdisciplinaire là on en est à
interthématique et le oneelse c'est
vraiment de l'interthématique enfin
c'est une vision holistique et
systémique très grande je sais pas si
j'ai
répondu
alors oui on me dit et c'est vrai
j'aurais dû finir par là mais commencer
le partenariat oneelse a été proposé par
la France ou sera proposé par la France
on sait pas si elle sera sélectionnée en
janvier 2024 mais cette vision ce
concept oneel c'est quelque chose que
l'on porte qui est apporté
pardon merci donc en tout cas je note
que l'intuition que que nous dans la
commission autour deun renforcement d'un
savoir holistique et en même temps qui
puisse se décliner de façon
opérationnelle sur sur sur la prévention
des des des conséquences des impacts des
pesticides n'est pas n'est pas inutile
et nous ESS nous continuons peut-être le
dialogue même après cette audition pour
voir comment formuler quelque chose qui
converge t qu'à faire voilà en tout cas
nos intuitions rejoignent les votes et
nous nous en réjouissons je dernière
question elle porte
sur sur le lien entre la recherche et le
développement on va vous épargner la
faillite du lien entre le développement
et l'accompagnement le Conseil qui est
qui est vraiment mais ça je pense que
c'est plus le ministère de l'Agriculture
que vous on pas vous en faire le
grief il y a une véritable incurie là on
n pas on n pas été jusque on n pas on
pas réussi à
massifier les solutions qui existaient
n'ont pas été massifié
bon par contre on a auditionné les
instituts on a auditionné plusieurs
filières et l'interrogation qui est la
note c'est de dire est-ce que on a assez
de challenger la recherche fondamentale
la recherche exploratoire et cetera pour
qu'elle se mette alors qu'elle continue
à à travailler pour le le 21e et le 22e
siècle mais qu'en même temps il soit
capable d'apporter des solutions
délivrables qui redonnent le moral dans
cela qui trouvent des solutions et
cetera pour gagner des des obtenir des
victoires des victoires maintenant et il
nous semble
que il y a quelque chose qui a failli
alors loin de nous l'idée de dire c'est
la faute de la recherche fondamentale de
tel institut et cetera mais est-ce que
vous prenez en compte cette question que
entre la recherche les instituts
techniques dans leur
diversité il y a du dialogue mais il y a
pas toujours assez a peut-être pas assez
de compréhension quel est le rôle du
ministre en la matière qu'est-ce qui
peut être améliorer et je je sais la
tension entre le besoin que toute la
recherche ne soit pas pleinement
orientée vers des solutions pragmatiques
parce qu'elle passera à côté des sujets
de demain et des de la hauteur de vue
qui doit être la sienne pour autant il y
a une sorte d'urgence est-ce que est-ce
que ce dialogue c'est bien c'est bien
opéré alors c'est une question qui
touche pas que ce domaine la question
que vous posez et c'est une question
aujourd'hui qui je dirais presque
pour moi et pour la majorité des
chercheurs aujourd'hui dans n'importe
quel domaine comme la la réponse au
défis et aux enjeux demande de casser
les silos disciplinaires et de favoriser
l'interdisciplinarité et ben c'est la
même chose par rapport au lien
fondamental appliqué et transfert et
innovation transfert c'est un continuum
je dirais qu'il y a des labos
aujourd'hui qui ne parle plus de
recherche fondamentale d'un côté ou de
recherche appliqué qui font le lien donc
oui c'est un quelque chose qu'on prend
en compte de plus en plus c'est quelque
chose qui devient euh je dirais très
porté par aussi bien les organismes de
recherche que par les universités les
sites je vous donne un exemple on a
lancé en juin dernier les pôles
universitaires d'innovation c'est pôle
universitaire d'innovation c'est quoi
c'est la façon de coordonner l'ensemble
des outils qu'on a mis l'ensemble des
outils c'est les incubateurs qu'on a mis
sur les campus c'est les sociétés de
transfert technologiques vers
l'entreprise ou de la création de
start-up qu'on a mis et c'est comment
aujourd'hui faire en sorte que dans tous
les laboratoires académiques la le la
découverte une découverte scientifique
on a le réflexe de la sortir en
innovation et en transfert donc on a mis
avec les P les et les France 2030 des
outils qui permettent d'aider ou
d'apporter des compétences pour faire le
lien entre l'entreprise et la recherche
académique de transfert de création de
start-up de valorisation et cetera de
gens qui savent ce que c'est que le
marché des gens qui identifient les
besoins dans le marché qui vont venir
chercher ce qui est fait dans les
laboratoire et qui vont vraiment
valoriser ça et de l'autre côté
aujourd'hui ces pui permettent de
coordonner donc un autre exemple c'est
linra linrae a une cellule recherche
innovation transfert qui a qui marche
bien aujourd'hui et qui permet d'une
part soit de créer des start-ups
d'accompagner le chercheur le doctorant
de créer des start-ups soit de sortir
une découverte d'un laboratoire et de la
mettre de la transférer à une entreprise
ou à une industrie et travaille
énormément dans ce sens avec les
instituts technologiques c'est c'est
voilà et je pense qu'il faut voir ça
comme un continuum il y a pas une
culture aujourd'hui oui il y a des gens
qui font plus de recherche fondamentale
et il en faut il faut continuer pour le
long terme mais dans un même labo dans
un dans des mêmes organismes il faut pas
remettre le silo de ceux qui font la
recherche fondamentale que ça et de ceux
qui font l'appliquer ou le transfert
sinon on va retomber à ce qu'on a connu
il y a des années c'est-à-dire que les
gens ne connaissent pas ce qui se fait
ne se parle pas et ne non'ont pas une
culture qui permet d'avoir ces échanges
et on a les bourses CIFRES ces bourses
CF ce sont des bourses de doctorat vous
les connaissez voilà qui font voilà et
c'est sur des outils comme ça qu'il faut
développer comme les Lab comm les
laboratoires communs entre un
laboratoire académique et un laboratoire
d'entreprise on a des laboratoires
commun avec un organisme une université
et une entreprise avec Talès avec
d'autres anofi et cetera ces
laboratoires commun sont financés par
l'ANR pour démarrer c'est tous ces
outils qui vont permettre
effectivement de faire ce ce ce
transfert et dans le domaine dont on
parle aujourd'hui et en particulier
l'inrae qui est un je dirais un un
organisme de recherche
alors fondamental mais aussi assez
finalement orienté dirigé qui a un
pilotage de la recherche et c'est cet
équilibre entre le déploiement des
politiques publiques la définition de
stratégie c'est la discussion qu'on
vient d'avoir tout à l'heure définir
oneels comment les projets et cetera et
bah la recherche fondamentale qui va
foissonner qui va alimenter le futur de
notre stratégie c'est le rôle de ces
agences de programme qui vont créer des
tuyaux entre l'alimentation par le
terrain et l'expertise scientifique pour
alimenter une politique publique faire
de des priorités et ensuite le même
tuyau utilisé pour redéployer cette
recherche dirigée cette recherche de
politique publique et dans ce
redéploiement il y a la valence il y a
la partie de dialogue avec les
entreprises de transfert alors je parle
d'entreprise mais là il faut aussi
parler des usagers et avec les
agriculteurs et par exemple à l'IRD au
CAD ou à à l'inrae et développer toute
une direction de sciences participativ
par exemple dans le PPR outremer il y a
une grosse partie de science
participatis qui veut dire quoi qui veut
dire on identifie le besoin avec les
usagers usagers pouvant être les
territoires d'outrem ou bien les
agriculteurs ensuite on fait la
recherche et ensuite on revient donner
bah les résultats de la recherche à ces
usagers qui vont essayer de mieux bien
l'utiliser et ensuite le déployer faire
ce que vous avez parlé c'est-à-dire la
massification donc que ce soit le
transfert que ce soit la diffusion de
culture scientifique ou que ce soit la
science participative c'est des axes que
l'on étudie et particulièrement dans ce
domaine là et dans le domaine avec l'
Rae c'est déjà en cours et c'est
vraiment quelque chose sur lequel il
faut qu'on appuie beaucoup si on veut
passer ensuite à la massification à
l'utilisation de la recherche qui est
faite dans les
laboratoires merci beaucoup madame la
ministre ce sont des des sujets qui sont
très ardus et merci de nous apporter ces
éclairages je suis comme le rapporteur
très preneur de ce que vous pourrez nous
nous fournir des CR puisse aider euh à
la rigueur de de la rédaction du rapport
et des recommandations j'auris pour ma
part deux questions avant de de passer
la parole à notre collègue Laurent séel
qui voudrait vous interroger aussi ma
première question vous c'est deux points
sur lesquels je souhaite revenir qui ont
été abordés en fait hein euh portent sur
euh euh la lisibilité de la politique
publique en matière de recherche
agronomique euh ma question c'est est-ce
que vous pensez que euh cette lisibilité
est suffisamment établie c'est-à-dire
que euh si on se projette un peu en
arrière au lendemain de la 2ième guerre
mondiale il y avait une une équation
très complexe à résoudre mais qui était
qui était quand même très claire il
fallait produire plus sur pas plus de
terre avec moins d'actif et pour moins
cher l'orientation de l'ensemble des
acteurs privés
public a été il y a une convergence
extraordinaire d'ailleurs des gains de
productivité en l'espace d'une
génération absolument fulgurant
euh qui ont largement conduit à la
dépendance à la chimie qu'on connait
aujourd'hui du reste puisque typiquement
la sélection a abouti à de bien
meilleurs rendement mais avec des des
variétés plus fragiles et plus
gourmandes pour pour le faire courbant
aujourd'hui vous diriez que c'est quoi
l'équation sachant qu'en fait on a un
système qui est quité évoqué qui est
complexe avec beaucoup de
paramètres l'eau la biodiversité le
carbone le revenu agricole la
souveraineté alimentaire l'optimisation
du système qui ne peut correspondre à la
maximisation d'aucun de ces critères
elle c'est une optimisation par rapport
à quoi enfin estce que est-ce que vous
diriez que les chercheurs de l'inrae du
CNRS de l'IRD alors IRD Sirat c'est plus
agrotropical mais
euh sont dans un alignement sur voilà
quelle est la politique publique de la
recherche agronomique pour euh euh bah
déployer la la transition attendue
est-ce que vous diriez que c'est
suffisamment clair ou est-ce que vous
pensez que ça devrait euh faire l'objet
d'un d'un momentum ou d'un
d'un politiquement d'une étape qui euh
qui permette de de justement de de de
cristalliser je dirais cette cette
politique
publique merci beaucoup pour pour cette
question parce que ça me permet de
préciser un petit peu certaines
évolutions peut-être en trois points
peut-être que si on
devait au niveau Scien et orientation
faire sortir je pense que aujourd'hui le
mot
agroécologie résonne particulièrement
est une direction parmi l'ensemble à
déployer et vraiment à regarder en
recherche agronomique donc ça c'est si
je devais en Cho enfin voilà donner le
deuxième point c'est la nécessité
d'avoir cette vision transversale et
aujourd'hui en tout cas au niveau
français ce qui joue le rôle au niveau
gouvernance pour moi d'une certaine
planification qui fait c'est le rôle du
sgpe qui effectivement coordonne et a ce
rôle aussi de gouvernance en plus vous
savez du comité scientifique avec
l'ensemble des ministères je je pense
qu'il faut pas oublier ce rôle d'gpe
parce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire la vision holistique la
vision systémique que tout blog dans
tout et donc on est obligé de définir
des projets avec des périmètres mais on
ne peut pas ne pas avoir à un endroit
oou au niveau des pilotages cette vision
transversale pour faire évoluer la
science et je pense que à la fois les
ministères ce comité Ori ce CSE avec les
ministères mais le sgpe dans la
gouvernance et quelque chose d'important
articulier et le dernier point que qui
que où je vous rejoins c'est comment les
chercheurs c'est votre question
c'est-à-dire le côté plus académique
déploie comprend comprennent la
politique publique participe à l'affaire
mais aussi la déploie efficacement et
comment on l'affiche et pour moi la
réponse est justement ce qu'on réfléchit
depuis pratiquement un an là qu'on est
en train de construire parce que c'est
un autant la France la la recherche doit
garder absolument ce côté bottom up pour
prévenir l'avenir mais l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre autant il faut qu'on qu'on
ait une coordination des acteurs
français sur les thématiques
prioritaires de recherche qui définit la
stratégie nationale de recherche et ça
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la complexité de
ces thématiques et leur imbrication fait
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on
l'organise et comment on l'organise ben
pour moi la réponse va être dans les au
niveau académique va être dans les
agences de programme qui va définir 6
SEP agences de programme qui
correspondent à tes thématique
prioritaire de recherche donc là on va
partir d'un état des lieux et poser le
paysage et donc ces agences vont être
coordonné par un acteur à l'intérieur
vont mettre autour de la table d'une
part tous les acteurs académiques je
prends l'exemple de la santé pour le
prendre il va être coordonné par l'inser
mais le CEA fait de la santé le science
de la vie le CNRS a un institut sciences
de la vie les universités font le
l'Inserm aura comme lettre de mission
comme mandat du gouvernement de
coordonner tous les acteurs et cette
lettre sera une lettre
interministérielle parce que même s'il
s'agit de recherche vous l'avez dit
c'est une recherche académique mais qui
doit aller jusqu'à la recherche clinique
en santé donc avec les hôpitaux donc
bien évidemment avec le ministère de la
Santé qui joue un rôle fondamental il
doit aller sur aussi les impacts que ce
soit l'utilisation du numérique parce
que la santé aujourd'hui sans
l'intelligence artificielle sans la
robotique n'est rien donc on voit bien
aussi d'autres volets importantes qui
sur lequel ça doit agir et puis bah tout
ce dont on parle aujourd'hui d' d'impact
environnementaux pesticides et cetera
sur la santé donc cette notion
d'interministérielle doit aussi être
présente au niveau de cette agence et
cette agence comme je le disais tout à
l'heure servira par la suite à faire
remonter des réflexions de tous ces
acteurs pour préparer la suite et
ensuite quand l'État deura défini sa
politique publique nouvelle de 2040 2050
s'en servira comme tuyau inverse pour
déployer efficacement sa politique
publique et je dirais jouer équipe
France au niveau des acteurs académiques
alors acteurs académiques qui sont le
cœur de ces agences puisque c'est sous
mon ministère mais évidemment si je
reprends l'exemple de la santé il y aura
dans les comités le rôle des industriel
parce que comme vous le disiez il y a ce
transfert et recherche clinique avec les
hôpitaux mais aussi médicaments ou so
enfin soins au niveau d'industrie mais
aussi les patients par exemple les
associations de patients donc on ouvre
et on est en train de réfléchir à
comment embarquer aussi bien cette
vision interdisciplinaire
interministérielle de politique publique
mais à l'intérieur une vision de
coordination des acteurs qui ne se
limite pas aux acteurs académiques même
si sa mission pour ces agences-l restera
académique et je pense que sur ces trois
volets donc les agences qui devraient
jouer ce rôle làà vis-à-vis de nos
chercheurs vis-à-vis de nos opérateurs
de recherch dans les deux sens je dirais
les orientations que l'on doit
coconstruire type c'est quoi pour
l'agriculture est-ce que l'agroécologie
comment on le décline et cetera et puis
ce rôle interministériel fort qui est
aujourd'hui joué par le
GPE merci
JAC la question peut être posée de
manière simple la réponse engage
énormément de de de de ce qu'on peut
percevoir comme des bouleversements dans
dans l'appareil d'État dans dans dans le
fonctionnement traditionnel de de de
différentes institutions que vous avez
vous avez évoqué avec cette j'en viens
avec cette vous avez évoqué la notion de
recherche
participative et là je ma deuxème
question porte sur la notion de
vulgarisation et culture scientifique
euh on a aussi à l'occasion de cette
commission d'enquête pu constater à quel
point il y a une des remises en
cause que je ne juge pas mon propos
n'est pas consiste pas à les juger mais
il est répandu en fait énormément de
doutes de suspici même sur la donnée
disponible sur la véracité de la donnée
disponible son caractère
scientifiquement fondé avec des
contradictions qui peuvent être
stupéfiantes à une échelle complètement
profane euh et qui remett en cause
évidemment la pertinence voire même la
probité de la décision publique on est
on est sur un un niveau de de de doute
et de suspicion y compris sur la
connaissance scientifique disponible sur
ce qui est vrai en réalité hein qui qui
qui atteint les proportions qui sont
inquiétantes rien en fait et donc ma
question porte sur sur tout ce que vous
nous avez décrit sur en mare de
politique publique et d'orientation de
long terme est-ce que cette question de
la Cult scientifique et de la
vulgarisation à une part parce que ça
s'improvise pas d'avoir des
scientifiques qui savent sans être alors
je crois savoir que vous
êtes je pense au domaine de la physique
quantique qui est un domaine très
abstrait c'est un langage mathématique
on a vite fait de raconter n'importe
quoi si on en parle en langage courant
et ça ça nécessite une une très très
solud
formation à la fois académique et une
formation en matière de communication
j'ai envie de dire pour savoir voir
adopter différents niveaux de langage et
ne pas être inexact tout en étant
imprécis ou approximatif pour se mettre
apporter est-ce que cette question là
occupe une place parce que il semble
quand même qu'en matière de de politique
publique et pour nous législateurs cette
dimension la culture scientifique et de
la vulgarisation elle est quand même
assez
centrale merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vais essayer d'être plus
synthétique parce que c'est une question
d'une part d'une telle importance et qui
peut aller très loin je vais c'est le
séquencer peut-être dans votre question
il y a plusieurs POS oui ça prend une
part et c'est important peut-être le
premier point et je vais aller très vite
c'est la science participative qui est
pas vraiment la culture scientifique
c'est ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est comment faire intervenir les
usagers dans le développement de
l'identification des problématiques et
ensuite dans le le la restitution de la
recherche et une meilleure utilisation
donc ce point-là est quelque chose comme
je vous l'ai dit en particulier sur
l'inrae dans nos domaines mais qui quel
quelque chose qui est de plus en plus
développé parce que que ce soit en santé
en incluant les les associations de
patients ou autres il est important
d'ensuite on le voit vous avez CIT le
quantique que je connais bien mais
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
est un exemple qui va être très vite
probant sur ça et effectivement l'accès
ça va créer des gaps si on ne fait pas
quelque chose sur comment utiliser
comment mieux utiliser parce que quand
effectivement la technologie l'évolution
scientifique est là il faut à la fois
mettre des limites des cadrages de
l'éthique mais aussi eTTH bien la rendre
accessible et l'utiliser intelligemment
donc c'est fondamental et le au niveau
de la recherche cette partie science
participative est en développée de plus
en plus dans les projets ensuite je vais
revenir à euh le côté euh sciences
culture de diffusion scientifique et
culture scientifique je pense que là
peut-être en deux points c'est quelque
chose que l'on travaille avec le
ministère de de l'éducation nationale
aussi parce que donner cette culture
scientifique on en a besoin en tant que
citoyen en tant que politique en tant
que journaliste en tant que beaucoup de
métiers qui n sont pas des métiers
scientifiques au sens cœur de métier
pour pouvoir comprendre le monde du 21e
siècle donc c'est clairement
effectivement quelque chose sur lequel
la base de culture scientifique doit
devenir dans l'éducation quelque chose
d'aussi naturel que les bases dont on a
l'abit ud depuis très longtemps et je
pense que la réflexion que l'on a avec
le ministre et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale dès la formation
de professeurs des écoles et la place
que prend la formation scientifique
jouera un rôle aussi pour que de petit
et bien on s'habitue et on n pas peur de
la science et dans la science c'est mon
troisème point je pense qu'il y a la
connaissance des domaines mais il y a la
méthode et la méthode scientifique vous
pouvez l'appliquer à je dirais n'importe
orte quel sujet c'est une façon
d'appréhender les choses c'est une façon
de dérouler un raisonnement c'est une
façon peut-être plus forte d'ouvrir un
esprit critique et je pense que quand on
parle de citoyen éclairé d'avoir une
méthode scientifique et ça ben
finalement on va la prendre en faisant
de la science mais presque je dirais que
la science c'est juste une excuse pour
développer la méthode scientifique et on
peut le développer science avec un Grand
T hein dans beaucoup de disciplines et
je pense que ça c'est un point important
pourquoi parce que quand vous parlez de
doute et de suspicion et de choses
contradictoires et bien le doute et la
contradiction dans la science
l'évolution de la connaissance c'est la
base de la méthode scientifique et ça il
va falloir je dirais en tant que
politique pour pouvoir être éclairé par
la science s'habituer que la science ne
peut pas vous donner quelque chose de
figé de sûr ou en tout cas pas tout le
temps mais peut expliquer effectivement
en quoi c'est sûr en quoi c'est pas sûr
quels sont les doutes quelles sont les
hypothèses de départ et la science est
fait de doute et d'hypothèsees alors
c'est quelque chose de difficile à
conceptualiser et à prendre surtout
qu'on en a besoin de prendre des
décisions mais oui la science pourra
vous donner une théorie à un moment et
50 ans plus tard la théorie aura évolué
parce que les connaissances aura évalué
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important et je finirai
par dans notre domaine euh ce que l'on
fait c'est-à-dire effectivement dans
tout ce qui est climat biodiversité mais
aussi bah impact agriculture mais
pesticides ou autres on a porté j'ai
porté le fait qu'à partir de
2025 tous les étudiants de premier cycle
dans l'enseignement supérieur auront une
formation aux transitions écologiqu et
de façon globale et ça je pense que
cette sensibilisation en plus de
formation plus spécifique est absolument
nécessaire à tous les niveaux et peut
être inclu même dans toutes les
disciplines dans tous les enseignements
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on est en
train de de monter comme le ministre des
fonctions publiques est en train de
développer cette formation à tous les
cadres de la fonction publique et pour
la diffusion de culture scientifique et
vous l'avez très bien dit comment un
scientifique peut formaliser de façon la
plus simple mais en gardant la plus
juste possible des concepts difficiles
mais au combien utiles pour comprendre
le monde et construire l'avenir
finalement et bien nous avons mis 1 % du
budget de la NR sur la diffusion de
culture scientifique nous avons
labellisé des projets scientifiques en
Scien avec et pour la société nous avons
inclu un label qui s'appelle le label
SAPS qui est science avec pour la
société aussi bien sur des projets que
aussi des établissements qui ont porter
des projets de diffusion de culture
scientifique sous ce label et nous
développons de plus en en plus pour les
doctorants je crois beaucoup au fait de
l'apprendre au moment du doctorat ce que
l'on appelle un complément au contrat
doctoral de recherche vous savez avant
les doctorants faisaient en complément
de l'enseignement ce que ce qu'on
appelait les monitorats et cetera
aujourd'hui ils peuvent être financés en
complément de leur contrat de recherche
pour faire un contrat d' de diffusion de
culture scientifique donc ils sont formé
parce que ça se forme vous l'avez très
bien dit on ne s'improvise pas médiateur
ou fusion et pour autant il faut avoir
des bases solides en sciences donc ils
sont formés et ensuite ils vont avoir un
projet soit auprès d'écoles de diffusion
de type la main à la patte avec des
associations soit auprès de grand public
avec des exposés et cetera mais avec des
projets pour la société et avec la
société avec des projets AR science par
exemple il y a des des festivaux des des
festivals AR sciences qui sont portés
par des universités par exemple et qui
sont beaucoup menés par des projets de
doctorant donc ce sont de multiples
projets en diffusion de culture
scientifique qui sont portés par le
ministère
aujourd'hui très bien très rassurant
merci Madame la Ministre madame
elle merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame la Ministre d'être là merci
d'apporter de la science nous avons
besoin de science dans nos
sociétés car bien évidemment on ne peut
se permettre de prendre une décision
sans avoir été éclairé au préalable pour
ma part j'aurais quelques questions
notamment en lien avec des éléments qui
ont été posés notamment par le par le
rapporteur et notamment sur la notion
des chiffres que vous allez évoquer
concernant l'effort de recherche fait
dans la
phytopharmacie quand on parle de
phytopharmacie de produits
phytopharmaceutiques de pesticides c'est
c'est une notion qui retrouve de
nombreux
produits donc si on donne des chiffres
d'affaires si on donne des des résultats
si on donne des bénéfices
aurons-nous la possibilité de faire des
distingot entre ce qu'on peut appeler
des pesticides dis chimiques des
pesticides dis naturel des biocides euh
de la recherche sur des insectes dit
stériles aurons-nous cette possibilité
làà parce qu'il serait regrettable que
l'on tire des conclusions actives de
montant de chiffre d'affaires par
rapport à cela par rapport à une
globalité pour ma part il me semble
qu'il est très important d'avant de
tirer des conclusions de savoir de quoi
on parle et donc je c'est pour ça que je
me permet de vous vous poser cette cette
cette première première question et et
ma deuxième ma deuxème question elle est
sur les types de travaux de recherche
qui sont faits en lien avec à nouveau
ces questions de prédateur que l'on
retrouve au niveau des exploitations
agricoles on a de nombreuses cultures
qu'on dit
orpheline notamment
l'arboriculture je vais citer la cerise
pour la parce qu'il faut que je la cite
ça peut être la noisette énormément de
filières où on a on n pas de solution
alors j'attends pas de votre part de me
dire comment vous comment on va faire
moi ma question c'est plutôt comment
fait-on pour qu'on ait de la recherche
sur ces productions d'itorpheline alors
bien évidemment je sais qu'il y a très
peu de producteurs euh je vais faire un
parallèle avec la médecine on a aussi
des maladies sur lesquels on a très peu
de malades et où on a besoin malgré tout
de travaux de recherche donc comment
est-ce que vous avez des pistes pour ces
filières où il y a peu d'acteurs peu
d'acteurs de qui produisent et donc des
chiffres d'affaires très réduit et donc
ça n'intéresse pas le privé et ça il
peut y avoir une certaine logique à ce
que ça n'intéresse pas le privé donc
comment fait-on par rapport à à à ce
type de à ce type de
filière enfin euh par rapport à
l'ensemble des intervenants qu'on a
qu'on a pu rencontrer jusqu'à maintenant
et vous avez déjà commencé à à y
répondre euh nombre ont ont évoqué une
une inadéquation entre les travaux qui
peuvent être menés par la recherche et
ce qui se passe sur l'exploitation
agricole est-ce que vous avez des des
des bouts de piste sachant qu'il est
évident que que l'on fait en laboratoire
ce que l'on fait sur une parcelle
expérimentale et ce qui se passe dans
une exploitation agricole où on est
censé vivre de son activité on est censé
produire suffisamment à la fois pour se
payer soi-même mais surtout pour payer
l'ensemble de ses intrants et l'ensemble
de ses salariés si on a comment est-ce
que l'on fait donc est-ce que vous avez
des éléments par rapport à ces
différents points je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la député
peut-être sur le dernier point l' enfin
le comment rendre plus en lien les
travaux enfin le monde de l'agriculture
et les travaux qui sont faits sur les
les les fermes les propriétés agricoles
et le monde de la recherche j'ai j'ai
peut-être deux pistes et c'est des
choses à travailler la première piste et
ça rejoint votre question sur comment
connaître euh finalement le spectre de
recherche ou toute la recherche qui
peut-être fait sur certains domaines je
pense que la porte d'entrée qu'on est en
train de créer sur ces agences de
programme pour moi est une des réponses
que l'on doit travailler c'est-à-dire
que si on a une agence de programme qui
est en lien avec l'agriculture euh qui
est par exemple coordonnée par l'inrae
dessous enfin il coordonne tous les
acteurs de la recherche qui travaillera
sur ces thématiqu-là et donc un de ces
rôles qui sera marqué dans la lettre de
mission c'est de tenir une sorte de
cartographie cartographie des acteurs
des laboratoires et cartographie des
thèmes et de ce qui s'y fait parce que
l'idée aussi c'est de pouvoir agir avec
les acteurs de façon plus fluide de leur
donner plus rapidement l'argent mais
tout en sachant où on le donne pourquoi
et comment et de façon plus fluide donc
son rôle d'avoir cet état de veille de
cartog graphie et de faire je pense
qu'il pourra être la porte d'entrée pour
pouvoir dire ben je j'ai ce problème
quelle recherche existe ou à qui je dois
m'adresser pour développer une recherche
qui peut m'apporter une réponse et c'est
vraiment l'objet la deuxième chose c'est
cette adéquation donc de la même façon
je l'ai dit c c'est on je dirais sur les
deux côtés quand on fait de la recherche
on travaille à développer la re re
cherche participative et l'inrae en
particulier travaille à se à bien
identifier les besoins des usagers des
utilisateur et de l'autre côté à comment
on transfère la recherche des labos avec
tous les outils que j'ai donné pour
travailler avec l'industrie pour adapter
à aux besoins agricoles là encore
peut-être deux réponses toujours cette
porte d'entrée je pense que dans la
gouvernance des agences il y aura les
usagers comme il y aura les industriels
donc cette notion de recherche
participative sera intégrée dans
lesémission et donc dans la gouvernance
premier point et deuxième point je pense
aux fermes défi aux 3000 fermes défi qui
ont expérimenté justement alors moi je
serais intéressé d'avoir puisque on nous
met je vois le qui ont ce réseau en fait
des 3000 ferme défilles puisque le
résultat qu'on a c'est une diminution de
la pression des des pesticides de 26 6 %
sans pour autant avoir d'incidence sur
le rendement et par l'utilisation par
les usagers donc l'idée c'est d'utiliser
ces expérimentations qui ont été faites
pour pouvoir continuer à les faire et
utiliser les
agences par rapport à ce point
malheureusement les fermes des filles ne
travaillent pas obligatoirement sur les
filières
orphelines voilà si vous pouviez amener
des du moins si vous aviez des éléments
par rapport aux filières orpheline merci
pardon alors je parlais des fermes
défilles par rapport à mieux identifier
et comment on expérimente avec les
agriculteurs avec les usagers j'étais
alors sur effectivement les les les les
cultures orphelines vous avez parlé de
la cerise il y a la noisette voilà et
comment donc deux réponses premièrement
qui fait vous rentrez par l'inrae et je
pense que cette porte d'agence de
programme sera d'autant plus utile
typiquement à ces sujets-là pour avoir
cette cartographie donc ça qu'est-ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui donc si je prends
l'exemple de la cerise parce qu'on l'a
pris un petit peu pour regarder c'est
effectivement comment fournir aux
agriculteurs des outils des méthodes
durables et efficaces pour protéger
typiquement leur culture des cerises
contre les attaques de la des insectes
et avec la mouche Drosophila Suzuki là
voilà donc c'est vrai que on a financé
avec l'ANR c'est de la financement
publicque ça répond à une de vos
questions tout à l'heure entre 2015 et
2021 il y a eu neuf projets de la NR
dont un projet é cofito maturation donc
qui développe des outils pour être je
dirais comment dire utilisé utilisable
directement par les utilisateurs et cela
représenta plus de 3 millions d'euros au
niveau de la cerise uniquement
d'investissement recherche donc vous le
connaissez je pense c'est vraiment euh
un cadre avec cette effectivement ces
recherches de de de de qui ont développé
ces insectes ça me vient plus mais vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure insectes
stériles merci beaucoup les insectes
stérribles et là on en est avec ce
projet de maturation à comment on
massifie ça et comment on passe à
l'échelle donc c'est de l'argent public
que ce soit au niveau de la recherche
fondamentale qu'ensuite au niveau de la
maturation puisque c'est typiquement du
soutien soit de la NR au départ soit de
France 2030 ensuite au niveau du
financement et je pense que ça a été
pareil pour la recherche les sur la
noisette les premiers travaux de l'inrae
qui ont anticipé un peu l'interdiction
des utilisations des produits ont porté
d'abord sur vraiment l'identification
des molécule responsable de de l' de
l'attraction là c'était le le Balana qui
typiquement par le noisetier et
travaille effectivement aujourd'hui avec
l'Association nationale des producteurs
de noisette et la coopérative par
exemple univoque et c'est Lina de
Versailles Grignon qui fait ce travail-
làà avec ses association sous cette
forme là donc c'est un travail qui est
en cours sur la noisette c'est un
travail qui est plus abouti sur la
cerise mais effectivement c'est plus de
l'argent public qui finance ses travaux
un peu de de ce queon appelle les
cultures
orphelines merci madame la ministre
c'est bon Melle vous avez pas de je
crois que le rapporteur a encore un él
demandé ah
pardon juste vous avez pas répondu sur
la question concernant le distingo sur
les éléments du moins je sais pas s'il y
a une réponse hein de en matière de de
de de chiffre d'affaires sur les
différents types du moins la réponse
c'est qu'on pourra pas avoir de réponse
on ne pourra pas avoir de distingo entre
une entreprise qui produira des
pesticides di chimiques dis Natur des
insectes stériles on aura donc des
chiffres
agglomérés nous effectivement moi je
peux pas vous donner cette réponse je
pense qu'on a moins accès nous et même
de savoir si on peut l'avoir ou pas je
je préfère pas vous donner cette
réponse mon le
rapporteur c'est pas on était un tout
petit peu distrait avec le Président
vous priez de nous excuser mais on on
analysait les conséquences en direct de
de de l'échec du règlement sûr c'est que
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y aura
pas il aura une nouvelle proposition de
la Commission mais on sera dans la
prochaine mandature donc on en reprend
pour 1 an 2 ans 3 ans des perspectives
qui sont pas du tout heureuses c'est un
événement absolument
majeur donc on était un peu on faisait
part de notre désolation commune et on
avait les dernières informations qui
arrivaient je en informé en même temps
donc c'est dur de de reprendre le fil
après tout ça mais juste une
critique du du plan français tel que
vous vous l'avez élaboré avec vos
collègues de l'agriculture de la santé
et de l'écologie il m énormément sur les
filières alors on nous dit c'est bien
parce que ça met dans le coup l'amont
enfin l'aval et c'est important que les
les distributeurs les transformateurs
les demain les consommateurs soient
associés à cette valorisation des
produits base
intran néanmoins toute la dimension
agronomique
territoriale paysagère ne doit pas en
souffrir est-ce que vous avez sur ces
questionsl c'est très technique hein
mais un avis quoi c'estàd que est-ce
qu'on est capable et c'est un appel
peut-être que je vous fais au-delà de de
de la commission d'enquête hein c'est à
veiller à ce que cette approche filière
ne soit pas prédominante alors même que
nous savons que ce n'est pas culture par
culture molécule par molécule que nous
trouverons les solutions systémiques euh
auquell appelle une ambition si elle est
maintenue par la France de in 50 % de
pesticidees première question et puis
euh je suis euh je je d'abord je
remercie notre collègue Laurence d'avoir
pointé la question des des cultures
orphelines il y a des enjeux de
territoire enjeux de de souveraineté
alimentaire nationale sur certains
secteurs donc c'est c'est un point
extrêmement important et et je note que
dans des logiques de péréquation et de
mutualisation des efforts singuliers de
recherche peuvent être faits là où le
marché ne répondra pas
spontanément il y a un autre domaine sur
lequel on est certainement en en retard
tard c'est notre autonomie en protéin
pour l'alimentation animale et
l'alimentation humaine est-ce que sur ce
point vous avez des choses à nous dire
et enfin dernière question j'en
terminerai par là avant de dire quelques
mot de conclusions moi aussi comme le
président l'a fait en introduction c'est
la question des néoncootinoïde alors
vous nêes pas responsable mais donc pas
coupable mais néanmoins en
2016 sous l'impulsion de Barbara
pompellie on interdit les nicotinoïdes
en AC un horizon 2020 j'ai posé la
question à Nicolas à deandie son prénom
Julien pardon Julien Julien de Normandie
en séance j'ai pas eu la réponse mais je
l'aurai avant la fin de la commission
d'enquête je vous l'assure c'est est-ce
que la recherche s'est mobilisée est-ce
que les instituts sont mobilisés pour
qu'on évite en 2020 de faire une
dérogation je ne suis pas persuadé qu'en
2016 quand on décide d'une introduction
pour 3 ans après on mobilise les moyens
de la recherche quelle conclusion
tirez-vous vous de cet échec patent
alors même que la dérogation est
justifiée par le fait que il faut au
moins 3 ans pour organiser la transition
et bien 3 ans avant on ne l'a pas engagé
donc trois questions une sur les
protéines je résume une l'approche le
croisement filière et territoire et
enfin sur les néonique est-ce que CIT
pas le signe d'une forme d'incurie dans
laquelle la recherche le Ministère de la
Recherche ne peut pas être totalement
innocent
merci alors je vais démarrer par la
partie filière vot dans votre question
filière peut-être pour effectivement
dire sur l'approche filière en tout cas
pour la recherche ça ne signifie pas
pour nous que les on va dire les
résultats sur la recherche sur une
filière soi cantonnés dans cette filière
quand on le regarde par rapport à la
recherche donc si on a une approche par
filière peut-être en deux points vous le
faire d'abord ça ne suppose pas un
isolement de la filière à son
environnement donc filière ne veut pas
dire indépendamment de considérer
l'environnement c'est vrai que le plan
plan national de recherche et
d'innovation qui a été lancé en
2021 qui qui visait à identifier pour
2023 les alternatives justement les
solutions alternatives typiquement ça
reviendra à la troisème question que je
prendrai après néonicotinoïdes
opérationnel contre la jaunice au niveau
des betteraves de la betterave
sucrière ça ça met vraiment en évidence
cette vision transversale donc le plan
global national de recherche et
d'innovation ce plan on l'a doté de 7
millions d'euros sur 3 ans et avec
quatre axes par rapport justement à ce
plan qui n'est pas que filière le
premier c'est une compréhension globale
de la situation sanitaire le deuxième
c'est l'identification et la
démonstration des solutions à l'échelle
de la culture le troisième c'est
l'identification et la démonstration des
solutions mais de régulation à l'échelle
de l'environnement des plantes des
cultures et des paysages vous disiez et
le 4è c'est la la transition vers un
modèle économique plus durable donc il y
a vraiment cet ensemble à prendre même
d'un plan global même quand on considère
une filière dans son environnement et de
dernier point peut-être c'est cette
approche filière qui effectivement ne
doit pas être exclusive parce que c'est
en particulier en recherche elle ne peut
pas être elle a des sujets communs entre
filières entre différentes filières et
des solutions communes je pense par
exemple dans le a des des alternatives
au désherbages chimiques on voit bien
que tout de suite ça s'applique entre
différentes filières et avec des des des
je dirais des des considérations un peu
communes donc c'est vrai
que même quand on regarde ou qu on
approche au niveau recherche par filière
obligatoirement on l'étend avec
différentes visions je vous ai cité les
quatre axes qui le montre bien en
particulier dans ce plan national qui
est ce plan de recherche et d'innovation
je sais pas si j'ai répondu mais je
pourrais vous apporter un complément
mais je pense qu'on le voit à peu près
le deuxième point sur les enfin
protéines euh je je peut-être vous
répondre je sais pas si c'est sur mais
dans alternative sur les légumineuses et
c'est vrai que sur ce point sur les
légumineuses clairement ces légumineuses
on le sait elles ont une capacité assez
unique de former des on va dire de ces
associations un peu symbiotiques avec
les bactéries et cetera mais en en tout
cas ça permet la fixation d'azote et ça
c'est très important dans pour
effectivement enrichir et continuer
d'azote atmosphérique au niveau du sol
donc ça a un impact très fort quand on
fait de la culture de des légumineuses
là-dessus c'est vrai qu'il y a des
recherches fondamentales qui sont menées
pour comprendre non seulement le
processus de fixation d'azote des
légumineuses mais aussi comment
l'améliorer donc on a tout un axe
là-dessus de recherche sur les
légumineuses et évidemment c'est
légumineuses dans on a une équipe
d'agroécologie à Dijon qui travaille sur
l'écophysiologie des légumineuses et qui
vont avoir un spectre assi large sur ces
problématiques là donc c'est je voudrais
citer quand même un point dont on n pas
eu l'occasion de parler mais à cette
occasion là c'est les infrastructures de
recherche donc associé au laboratoire et
typiquement dans ce cadre làà on a une
infrastructure de recherche qui
s'appelle phénom qui a bénéficié d'un
financement qui est quand même de 29
millions d'euros entre 2012 et 2024 qui
est ouverte c'est-àdire ouverte au
laboratoires ouverte aux industriels et
qui permet justement de regarder ces
interactions entre plantes
micro-organismes pour cette production
et aussi la caractérisation de tout ce
qui est matière et matériaux végétal
donc les légumineuses profitent
particulièrement en particulier de cette
plateforme phénome pour pouvoir
caractériser améliorer et comprendre ben
les comment ça fonctionne finalement à
ce niveau-là donc c'est un je pense une
des réponses aussi dans les alternatives
au niveau protéines et aussi des
réponses au niveau environnemental et
des règlements climatiques qu'on apporte
et c'est un domaine de recherche un peu
prioritaire très forte comme exemple qui
peut illustrer alors sur le dernier
point et on pourra vous donner une fiche
complète typiquement sur ça en
complément sur les légumineuses fournir
laffiche sur les
néonicotinoïdes alors moi j'étais pas là
donc je je veux dire c'est vraiment des
choses qui se sont passées entre 2016
2020 pour voir comment développer
peut-être deux points quand même les
néonicotinoïdes c'est pas quelque chose
de spécifique au sens que quand on fait
de la recherche dans les pesticides on
ça inclut entre autres les
néonicotinoïdes donc c'est vrai que
cette recherche sur les pesticides c'est
une recherche qui a lieu depuis très
longtemps qui est très forte en France
je pense qu'il faut bien voir qu'au
niveau européen et ce qui n'enlève rien
aux problématiques au combien importante
que vous traités et qui sont capitales
mais au niveau de la recherche on est
leader dans ce domaine au niveau de
l'Europe pas que néonicotinoïde hein
mais pesticides et autres je pense que
l'inrae est sur ces points-là et euh on
on est vraiment très très bien placé sur
la recherche dans les pesticides de
façon générale les on a quand même
financé en entre 2008 et
2022 250 projets 251 exactement qui
affiche dans le titre le mot clé ou dans
les mots clés le mot pesticides et c'est
un montant de
108,6 millions d'euros qui ont été
financés sur cette période là donc vous
voyez qu'il y a eu une intense recherche
sur les pesticides depuis 2008 jusqu'en
2022 avec en moyenne 17 projets par an
et un budget sur les pesticides de 7,2
million d'euros par an donc c'est loin
d'être négligeable et les
néonicotinoïdes faisait partie entre
autres de ces pesticides et de l'AX
recherche écopyo ça c'est un premier
point ensuite euh je pense
qu'effectivement en 2020 la France a été
confrontée à
cesestations de inédite de jnis sur les
betteraves avec un fort impact sur les
rendements ce qui a fait donner lieu au
plan nation de recherche et d'innovation
le pnri vraiment qui a été unique en
Europe et qui a eu pour objectif de
trouver ces solutions alternatives aux
néonicotinoïdes ce coup-ci vraiment
puisque il y avait cette problématique
spécifique et c'était un plan très
opérationnels contre la jeunise des
betteraves sucrière donc je pense qu' il
fait vraiment partie finalement des
Programm particulier de type problème
solving vraiment dans son ensemble à
prendre et je pense que ça c'est une
approche intéressante dans ce cas-là
issue des besoins vous l'avez dit hein
générés par le retrait des molécules et
qui a été focalisés sur les
néonicotinoïdes mais on a eu aussi en en
2000 je sais plus c'est 2018 ou 2020 sur
les néodécotinoïdes les recherches ont
par exemple mentionné qu'il existait des
alternatives possible au néonictinoïde
issu de travaux de recherche comme on
témoigné à l'époque à l'époque de
l'interdic en 2016 un rapport de
l'ancesse donc je pense que si la
recherche n'a pas focalisé comme après
avec le plan pnri en 2020 sur les
néonicotinoïdes il en existait sur les
pesticides de façon générale et quand il
y a eu l'interdiction il avait été dit
dans un rapport de l'anè qu'il y avait
des alternatives chimiques au niveau de
de de l'interdiction ce qui a expliquer
le non focus finalement néonicotinoïde
qui est arrivé après lorsqu'il y a eu la
jonice donc voilà pour naesser ou en
tout cas à postériori d'explication en
essayant de reconstituer cette
historique par rapport aux recherches de
pesticides au plan pnri et à ce qu'on
trouvait à ce moment-là dans les
rapports de l'ancess qui pouvait penser
que il y avait une alternative
possible alors je dis pas uniquement
pour votre audition mais pour l'ensemble
des auditions les meilleures choses ont
une fin c'est on a essayé de prolonger
un petit peu le le plaisir d'être
ensemble mais c'est c'est on clôture
donc les les auditions sous l'autorité
du président ça relève de de son
autorité et je lu fait quelques
suggestions de de d'autres d'autres
auditions mais on les fera en parallèle
et dans d'autres formats parce que il
faut préserver les forces de de nos
administratrices et de l'ensemble des
équipes qui ont été extraordinaires dans
cette période il y a un travail de de de
relecture de de de l'ensemble des
auditions du matériel qui a été accumulé
de la documentation on a une matière
extraordinaire euh je vais poursuivre
moimême vous l'avez compris quelques
investigations dans dans les ministères
concernés dans dans les dans les jours
qui viennent pour compléter notre
documentation être le plus explicite
possible sur ces sujets et puis nous
devrons rédiger nos propositions en les
confrontant euh à nos collègues
commissaires qui se sont c'est pas
visible aujourd'hui mais il y avait
d'autres enjeux politiques et des
réunions des maires et cetera mais on a
été plutôt très nombreux et je m'associ
au président pour saluer l'engagement
des commissaires dans toute la période
sur les 6 derniers mois le plus dur
reste à faire c'est c'est c'est faire la
synthèse rendre compte et tracer une
trajectoire encore une fois je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de redire à quel point je
suis dépité le mot est faible par la
décision européenne c'est un mauvais
message pour pour l'Europe c'est un
mauvais message pour nos territoires
pour la santé c'est un mauvais message
pour le Green Deal c'est un mauvais
message pour la planète qu c'est je suis
je suis dépité c'est le le mot est
faible mais je voudrais redire ma
gratitude à tous ceux qui qui ont
coopéré à cette à cette commission
d'enquête le travail n'est pas terminé
en période cible je le donne comme
information publique à cet instant parce
que pour le coup ça ça relève de de
notre autorité commune avec le Président
nous cherchons à rendre notre rapport
pour ne pas qu'il soit à la veille des
fêes à rendre notre rapport le le 14
décembre qui suppose une mise à
disposition du document vers le 8-9
décembre auprès des des commissaires une
mise à disposition du document et pour
un compte-rendu de la commission compte-
rendu public le le 14 c'est notre cible
on n'est pas sûr d'y parvenir et la
publication du rapport serait donc la
semaine suivante après les 5 jours de de
de de de précaution qui qui conviennent
enfin je sais pas comment ça s'appelle
mais de il y a 5 jours de de réserve
quoi en tout cas avant la publication du
rapport donc on serait on est
parfaitement dans les temps qu'une
semaine d'avance pour éviter le
télescopage avec les fêtes de fin
d'année et un autre débat qui va
passionner notre pays celui sur
l'immigration donc on essaie de se
glisser dans un temps de de de ce ce
rapport et ses conclusions puissent être
reçu sereinement dans dans notre pays
euh alors malgré la difficulté qui
estannonce comme un dernière audition et
annonce décision européenne c'est un
petit peu difficile je voulais vous
remercier Madame la Ministre et et vos
équipes et et saluer encore une fois
l'engagement de l'Assemblée nationale et
et me féliciter je leur dirai au moment
du compendu de rapport de
l'excellente coopération que nous avons
eu avec le président tout au long une
exigence partagée l'un avec l'autre mais
une coopération totale avec le souci de
non pas de faire de la communication
mais de chercher la vérité et d'être
utile au pays
merci c'est à moi de vous renouveler mes
remerciements j'étais personnellement
sensible au soucis que vous avez eu de
précision et d'être complète dans vos
réponses nous avez apporté énormément de
matière donc merci pour cette
disponibilité merci pour vous être prêté
à l'exercice avec avec autant d'exigen
euh je m'associe au remerciement du
rapporteur au membres de la
commission madame bel je citais ce matin
les membres de la commission qui avaient
été les plus assidus vous en êtes donc
il y a une une vraie contribution aux
travaux je renouvelle aussi j'y tiens
les remerciements aux administratrice
Pascal Rans Olivia Sanson et Charlotte
titicard pour le remarquable travail
très très qualitatif que vous fournissez
qui nous permettent comme député de
conduire ce genre de travaux et je
confirme que
le niveau de complicité de conivance
intellectuelle entre rapporteur et
président pour l'exigence des travaux a
était un vrai plaisir je je m'associe
tout à fait à
cette c'est un motif de fierté voilà
alors c'était notre dernière audition
nous nous retrouvons donc le 14 pour
examiner le et adopter le rapport de la
commission et je je lève cette séance
pour aujourd'hui